going back to the webby awards and
Zoey's brain what do you think the one
or the one thing or the sequence of
events world that launched your career
because so many people are presented
with opportunities one documentary that
we love called my big break says
everybody is actually given a big break
but they don't realize what it is when
it happens oh I think by mm I was 26 and
you know I was worked in technology to
pay for my films that was normal it is
and I was doing a gig I was designing a
website for a magazine called the web
magazine and I you know I just finished
the job and I knew how to do things on
no money cuz that's an independent
filmmaker and the publisher said you
know we own the word webby awards and we
you create the webby awards and I was
like absolutely and you know they you
know so I'd raise all the money I hated
most a war chest I got to completely
rethink award show so we made acceptance
speeches five words or less and we
rethought award shows we had all these
cool funky films and we really it was
very edgy you know the first years and I
mean ironically it's become more you
know towards the center but it's still
edgy and they suck the five word
acceptance speech and I did it for
nearly five years but that was a huge
opportunity and
definitely you know in some ways I think
you know I was making films and I did
the webby awards it was a whole decade
of my life and I got back to making
films with technology but I would not
have traded it for anything the business
experience i got from you know running
that growing the webby awards during the
internet film was like crazy to be under
30 in san francisco in the 90s was an
amazing time and then you know the
internet crash happened and the
financial crash happened and learning
how to manage that and then build the
web ease back up and then sell it and
then go and start my film studio with
what I had learned I mean it was such a
great experience and I'm got to really
watch the web for a year and think about
it not here a decade think about it and
now all of our films are experimenting
with the web so it's like totally my
sweet spot film the web experimenting
social change it's like we're having so
much fun right now I felt like all of my
career led to this time where I'm just
you know having such a wonderful time
making movies and great team so maybe
saying yes when someone else might have
been presented and he's scared and
saying you know what I'm not going to
shy away I have the moxie yes that was
definitely one when I was so young I
mean I think about it now yeah did you
have any hesitation do you remember back
to that day when your boss came to me
did you have any like maybe this is he
not too much it was alright i was ready
i mean i knew i could do something
really special so many award shows i
feel like are so wrote and boring i love
i love when I can do something totally
different and I was given a blank slate
to do something totally different that's
that is very exciting to me when there's
no when I can really rethink how
something is done that's always that's
always interesting to me that's why the
film and internetworld feels to me now
the film filmmakers still don't totally
use all the internet tools and
technology they're just starting but to
me it's like an open space to play and
rome and experiments and it's so much
fun what do you think filmmakers
to neglect that they're not using
YouTube or they're staying away plus
some up there's a lot of filmmakers of
course crowdfunding and figuring out how
to engage their audience and they're
making of it I mean I there's definitely
great filmmakers doing it but the
majority I mean because you know a lot
of conferences all be speaking about
what we're doing there's a small number
of us that are always on these panels so
I want it to be more it's like the more
of us the stronger we are and the more
we can share what works and what doesn't
so but i still think filmmakers you know
sentence social media but this goes back
to the business stuff oh i just want to
make my movie I don't want to worry
about I mean these work you know
marketing my fellows to me it's not
marketing it's it's engaging it's like
bringing people your film and so I think
looking at these tools as part of the
process and build in a budget in
addition to your film production budget
to a budget to get your phone out into
the world and to be able to experiment
with these new technologies is really
important it should be partying budget
should be part of your energy it should
be part of the time that you divide when
you're thinking about a film from the
beginning
you